[Musique]
les chats les positions
désormais les talibans contrôlent les
trois quarts du territoire afghan
[Musique]
pour
à demain
[Musique]
on
la façon dont nous avons pu avancer
n'était pas attendue nous n'avions
jamais pensé pouvoir avancer aussi vite
mais dieu nous a donné cette victoire
[Musique]
ces étudiants
m
[Musique]
leur
il
je ne sais pas
la population docile et épuisé par des
années de guerre subi le visage
inexpressif
personne n'ose plus dire ce qu'il pense
des aliments sont des gens très bien
c'est la situation à djalal abad est
très bonne mais on en voit la sécurité
et rance était
commandant taliban avant les talibans
ils n'osent pas répondre les talibans ne
sont pas loin
or seuls enclave encore sécurisée
des familles entières qui veulent s'en
fuir à tout prix
[Musique]
un vidéaste amateur film des afghans
prêt à prendre tous les risques pour
monter dans cet avion militaire
américain
kraft de la lumière à cette crainte
d'euros de retombées finalement dans ses
manières
obscurantistes de dérision tellement
entre 1996 et 2001 qui pousse des
milliers d'afghans à vouloir scheer le
fait nul
[Musique]
sous leur administration ce n'est plus
que femme voilée rétablissement des
châtiments islamiques interdiction des
jeux de hasard et de la drogue bref
stricte application de la loi coranique
[Musique]
elles ont certes le droit de sortir mais
intégralement voilée est accompagné d'un
maram un homme de leur famille proche la
façon dont on traite les femmes c'est
normal c'est prévu par l'islam l'islam
dit que les femmes ne doivent pas
travailler c'est dangereux pour la
société
vous les étrangers vous vous demandez
sans arrêt pourquoi les femmes ne
travaillent pas moi je vous réponds nous
savons ce que nous faisons
[Musique]
pour rentrer chez elles après les gants
mais elles ont été arrêtés et fouillés
des parce qu'elles portaient des
temps déjà et on voit déjà des des
rapports de deux petites filles et
adolescentes qui sont prélevés dans leur
famille donner aux combattants talibans
pour être mariées de force
je